before we leave the panel an update on a
favorite panelists here I've updated you
several times about the health and
status of our colleague Charles
Krauthammer number times on the show
before but of the questions I get on
email and Twitter and Facebook
how's Charles tops the list by far
Charles has as I've said been recovering
from complications after a surgery for
several months now I check in with
Charles more than I tell you a lot but
today in my communication he had a
message he wanted me to share with you
the viewers of special report quote
things are progressing steadily slower
than I would like but steadily still I
wish I could give you and myself a
better idea of when this marathon ends
I'm sure it is strange for your viewers
that a regular panelist should disappear
for months without warning and without
any real explanation after my surgery
there were serious complications that
took several months to stabilize my
improvement medically has finally
allowed me to concentrate on intensive
rehabilitation to recover my strength
and stamina this too is progressing well
but as usual is intense and slow
nonetheless I am determined to make it
back I've got to I can't let you guys
have all the fun
Charles we miss you and your voice on
the big issues facing us every night we
continue to hope and pray for your
speedy recovery and until then we'll
keep your spot warm right here